what's up guys and welcome to Haris
hobbies the channel where we discussed
the latest tech news and delve into
newest tech products today we're taking
a look at if you should snatch a new
rise in CPU due to the crazy deals are
ongoing right now for example the rise
in 312 hundred is at an all-time low for
its price so should you snatch one of
these while you have the chance but
before we discuss that make sure to
subscribe to this channel if you already
haven't to be updated with the latest
tech news related to gaming and pcs so
first of all before we talk about if you
should buy it we talked about why the
price are dropping in the first place so
why aren't the prices dropping well if
you guys didn't already know
Rison 2 is just around the corner and
it's coming up very soon as a result
retailers want to sell out all their
inventory because after rising 2 comes
out people will be more inclined to buy
rise at to insert verizon 1 + + rice & 2
is offering some great value and so it
doesn't really make sense to go back and
buy an outdated product after that so
their sales will go down a lot and so
they want to be able to sell out
everything before it's too late
also according to some leaked specs
first of all these are leaked spec so
keep that in mind
but anyway according to some leaked
specs the flagship of the next series
which is the 2,700 X has a max frequency
of four point three five gigahertz and a
base frequency of three point seven get
Hertz with eight cores and 16 threads
and it only cost 370 dollars at MSRP if
you guys remember last generation a -
1800 X was pretty close to it in specs
maybe around like nine ten percent less
performance but it was 500 dollars so
it's obviously one hundred and thirty
dollars so if these leaks are true then
retailers probably know about that and
they know that once a consumer knows
about this no one's actually gonna buy a
rise in C pute because they know that
even though the rise in to CPU is more
expensive it's actually better because
the 800 X is on a crazy deal right now
and that's why it's $330 while the rise
in 227 or X is not on a deal it's just
an MSRP but it's very close to in price
plus the 2,700 X
actually come to the rated prism cooler
so that's an added value right there so
as you guys can see the next generation
of CPUs from AMD is coming out very soon
and it is thought to have a significant
performance upgrade at about 10% and it
brings much more value to the market and
so retailers want to get their rise in
one CPUs out as soon as possible and
that's why you are seeing all these
crazy price drops in the last few days
so should you buy one right now or wait
well in my opinion I think there are
three reasons why you guys should just
wait a little bit more until rising to
release to make that final decision so
as for the first reason when rising 2
comes out not only as fries and one
gonna drop but it's motherboards are
also gonna drop so this can be a full
downward trend for the prices of
original rice in one product and the
things that go along with it so as a
result you might be able to see 20 or 30
dollars off flick beats me 15 x3 70
motherboards and same goes with the rise
in one CPUs as well as a result you guys
can save a good amount of money by
simply waiting for the next generation
of CPUs to come out ask for reason
number two using that money you guys
saved from waiting you guys can actually
upgrade your CPU for example let's say
you were thinking about buying the 1800
X with a X 370 motherboard so let's say
that X 370 motherboard goes down by
$30.00 so let's say you're planning to
buy a 18 or ducks right now for the
retailer price of 330 dollars and get
the motherboard for let's say $200 just
for sakes so now you're saving $30 you
can use that same money and guess what
and now you can get a rise in to 2700 X
for the same price using that money you
saved you would only have to spend an
extra $10 to be able to afford it and
plus Amy is very lenient and they let
rise and two CPUs work with X 370 and
beat 350 motherboards from first
generation so that's definitely a plus
and it gives you much more flexibility
on upgrade options so overall if you
wait just live it more you may even be
able to get a better product for the
same price that you are willing to spend
right now as for reason number three
the new CPUs are actually bringing the
same value as current Steve use for
example think about the 1,800 X 8 core
16 threads 3.6 gigahertz and 4 gigahertz
right and that costed $500 at the
beginning and now it's discounted at
$330 so if we divide the a Hertz by the
amount of dollars of spending at the end
for every dollar you're spending you're
getting 12 point 1 megahertz of
performance now let's do the same math
with the 2700 X it's 3.7 gigahertz base
and 4.35 can here's a boost so if we
divide that 4.35 by the price of three
hundred and seven dollars then you get
eleven point eight megahertz of
performance per dollar as you can see
it's very close eleven point eight and
twelve point one and did I forget to
mention the 27 of our X comes with the
rate the prism cooler so if you were
thinking about getting the 1,800 X with
a normal air cooler like the hyper to
Tokyo which would cost about three
dollars then you don't have to do that
with 2700 X because it comes with it so
we're in reality the 2700 X only cost
340 dollars because it also includes the
cooler so when you do the math then 4.2
be five divided by three hundred and
forty dollars we're actually getting
twelve point eight megahertz of
performance for every dollar you spend
so by waiting and buying xx 7 over X or
any of the rise in two CPUs you're
actually getting the same value if not
more value by weighting so those are the
three reasons you guys should wait you
can get more performance or save a bit
of money as a bonus reason you can go
and tell your friends that you're on the
most latest platform available so if you
guys care about that that's definitely a
plus as well next up I should just buy
the current generation rising CPUs
if you think they're a good deal and you
don't care for more performance well I
mean if you don't really care about a
little bit more performance that you're
gonna get or a little bit money you're
gonna save then I guess yes you might as
well just go and buy it because you're
still gonna be satisfied with it and
it's gonna perform the same that's
always been performing so there's not a
performance loss it's just that you
could get more performance but since you
don't care about that it's alright but
if you're on the fence here like I would
like more performance but at the same
I don't know if it's worth waiting then
let me tell you it's definitely worth
waiting again ten percent more
performance and at a cheaper price than
it's ever been offered before so it's
definitely a worth waiting also Amazon
the CPUs are actually twenty eight
thirty dollars less for example think
about the eighty seven hundred K right
now it's usually three hundred and sixty
dollars but right now on Amazon Sony 330
so the horizon 2 2700 X may even be
cheaper which will be even bigger value
for you guys so I would definitely
recommend that you guys wait because you
guys can get a significant amount of
more performance or save a bit of money
too so that's why you should or
shouldn't wait for the rise in two CPUs
but either way these rise in two CPUs
actually bring up a lot of debate as
what Intel is going to do think about
how much we've been ripped off for the
last couple of years by in tow like
literally just one year ago that 7700 K
which is the flagship of --into only had
four cores and eight threads and space
frequency was 4.2 and it's max was 4.5
years as you guys can see it's very
comparable to the horizon 2 2700 X when
you think about it as double performance
you're getting double the amount of
cores at almost the same max speed at
four point three five gigahertz so we
really think about it it's almost double
the performance I know that Intel CPUs
are a bit more optimized and there have
more overclocking Headroom but when you
really think about it it's actually
insane how much value ami is giving us
right now but that's pretty much all I
have for you guys this time make sure to
comment what you guys are thinking about
this in the comments down below for
example do you think all these specs and
prices that have been leaked are
completely false or do you think aimed
II would do something like this also how
do you think Intel is gonna respond do
you think Intel is now forced to bring
out eight core 16 thread CPU onto the
mainstream platform or do you think
that's what they already have planned
for the z3 90 make sure to post what you
guys are thinking in the comments down
below I do read all my comments and I'm
curious as to what you guys think also
if you guys like this video then make
sure to drop a like on it and don't
forget to subscribe and hit that Bell
notification if you guys want to be
notified every time I post a new video
and would like to see more videos just
like this one but until next time bye
[Music]